não me engano em um mesmo playboy
a história que nós não contará em quase
vinte anos estávamos em 1995 eu ensinava
no ensino profissional e num dos módulos
português sem tema específico eram os
alunos que sugeriam os assuntos a tratar
na aula
um dos grupos promon toma o nosso tema
pode ser sobre a internet
eu não sabia do que se tratava e conclui
aliás josé o concurso vai e sempre quis
que os alunos não surpreende assim
porque eu sei que eu sabem coisas que
nós aí podemos aprender juntos no dia da
apresentação fomos na sala de
informática
nessa altura os sites eram poucos os
portugueses que contavam os dedos e foi
preciso me âmbito site da playboy que
serviu para introduzir a internet na
aula de português
o que recorda essa aula de vir umas
linhas numa colina e alguns títulos e
thais é o sinal era tão fraco que
gastamos praticamente é aula toda a ser
ao site precisou então meu e dos alunos
mas valeu a pena porque é um admirável
mundo nasceu pra mim e me trouxe até
aqui hoje eu sinto muito orgulho em
dizer que tenha aprendido muito com os
meus alunos
eu não sabia nada de computadores e fui
um aluno que me ajudou a fazer o meu
primeiro webby site no final do século
passado por esta altura e ouvir os
alunos falar em total mirka para falar
com gente do mundo inteiro
fiquei com uma pulga na orelha e fui ver
o que era
navegando em sites francesas foi terá
salas de conversação e numa das salas
encontrar um jovem escritor francês é
que acaba de ser premiado do aço o seu
primeiro mas a nave do idioma
nessa altura eu tenha de lecionar é uma
obra literária na turma francesa
é em vez de seguir o programa achei que
era muito mais interessante para os
alunos estudarem uma obra do monge o
autor vivo com o qual pudessem interagir
quanto à ideia aos alunos não ficarão
sob todos entusiasmados
o escritora enviou um exemplar do livro
por ray ou para a escola
photoshop e os capítulos distribuídos
pelos alunos e à medida que o window
into uma nota g escrevendo as perguntas
que iriam fazer ao escritor
no dia do chat via um projetor porque
criei que todos os alunos acompanhassem
é conversa
os alunos cada grupo foram se
apresentando e colocando as suas
perguntas
infelizmente é internet era tão lenta na
altura estamos a falar em 2000 é que só
deu pra colocar de três ou quatro
questões as outras foram enviadas forem
malu e o escritor fez o favor de me
responder e depois foram comentadas pelo
pt os grupos mas eu tenho a certeza que
esta experiência ainda hoje é lembrada
por estes alunos porque pela primeira
vez aula francês deixou de ser uma
situação simulada para ser uma asa ou
situação real com fixação
aliás esta experiência foi o pela o
pontapé de saída para é os vários
projetos de iluminação que eu tenho
vindo a fazer desde 2004
ainda esta semana a minha escola civil
dois selos de qualidade twinning os
projetos que desenvolveu o passado ano
lectivo é com turmas do 9º ano e do
décimo
o projeto geração móvel
nesse eu tenha se dado que o sentir do
potenciar os dispositivos móveis que os
alunos levam para a sala de aula lutar
contra a sua proibição quebrando
paradigmas no início
do ano faço sempre levantamento dos
dispositivos móveis que os alunos têm a
receber concurso e que posso contar com
a planificação minhas aulas claro
fazemos também as regras de utilização
porque eu quero uma escola que educa não
quer uma escola que apenas proíba
quando eu digo aos alunos que os seus
dispositivos móveis não estão proibidos
nas minhas aulas no atual que em alguns
olhares um sorrisinho e um brilhozinho
nos olhos mas também nota em alguns
alunos alguma desconfiança mas à medida
que os vão usando os aparelhos vão
sentindo que são benéficos para a sua
aprendizagem e integração faz
naturalmente quando o web 2.0 pulsava a
dar os primeiros passos estávamos no ano
lectivo 2004/2005
tive um aluno com doença prolongada
então decidi gravar em áudio é o assunto
da aula e publicá los na internet para
que o aluno em casa pudesse acompanhar
as aulas
ouvindo a voz da pessoa professora ana
depois pelos alunos entusiasma e acabei
por gravar as obras fazem parte do
programa português do ensino secundário
desde o quadro antônio vieira até
fernando pessoa
este pode kasten sido usados por
professores e alunos norte a sul do país
voltem mayer sebo na minha caixa de por
raio é em maio sabe ouvir mais episódios
é e outros agradecer pelo facto dos meus
podcasts terem ajudado é procurar testas
exames e já lá vai uma década que eu
gravar e publicar e os primeiros quando
publicamos recursos na interna é que
nunca sabemos a quem é que aos
beneficiários no mês de setembro passado
estive a fazer um workshop no
agrupamento de escolas em pombal e uma
professora soube que eu estava lá e ela
nem quis acreditar porque
toca a glória mas é mesmo modo lima
moura aquela professora que tenha que os
materiais doados publicados na internet
quando não cumprimentou emocionada disse
a colega não imagina como seus materiais
têm sido úteis primeiro aos meus alunos
entre os poucos casos mais fala famoso
uma maior escola viva em casa maya
méxico por maria em coimbra descendente
de uma família abastada que já estava
afastada e agora vai estudar os mais uma
dor de cabeça para os alunos pensavam em
tempo ler umas mais 300 páginas então é
preciso motivá los e animá-los depois de
estudarmos as partes mais importantes da
obra desafia os alunos el irem resumirem
os testes depois sobre os vários
episódios dos romãs e depois
transformados nos resumos e letras de
rap para gravar em vídeo e em áudio e
publicarmos no blog da turma
escusado será dizer que tive aulas muito
participada shani mamadas e com muito
rápido maio o jogador que pensa então
estudar é poesia françois é um autêntico
por pio pois são poucos os alunos que
gostam de poesia entanto vídeos que com
os seus telemóveis
a captação em uma bela imagem e que por
fazerem um emblema é várias mãos
inspirados por essa imagem através de
sms
depois disso espera no repositório de
poesia de fernando pessoa encontrassem o
melhor sms poético e enviassem a uma
pessoa muito especial com os poemas dos
alunos
criamos um bruxo jura que serviu para
estudar a obra de fernando pessoa nas
aulas e ver seria o impor com a sempre
acontece os poemas a estudar
foram os problemas dos alunos ea os
alunos tiveram
vezes nas aulas depois fizemos um peddy
paper literário composto por provérbios
é um questionário sobre é poesia de
fernando pessoa é e também provas
físicas e devo dizer que este peddy
paper literário é os alunos estiveram
envolvidos em todo o processo de
elaboração
uma das chaves para o sucesso no século
21 é o desenvolvimento de competências
digitais depois termos estudado a obra
levou a herdeira da marca
os alunos do 7º ano desenvolveram todo o
processo de criação de narrativas
audiovisuais desde o uso meio das
histórias de composição das personagens
a animação dos brinquedos que trouxeram
pra aula até a escrita do guião depois
com os seus smartphones gravaram os voz
e fizeram as filmagens
o resultado foram cinco narrativas
digitais que partilhámos no youtube no
fundo transformar os alunos dos 5 os
consumidores à informação para
produtores também do conteúdo
uma das minhas preocupações nas aulas é
que os alunos estejam ativos e motivados
mas quando temos uma obra literária como
mundial do ambiente
relacionar e sabendo que em papel
fica muito difícil então para introduzir
esta obra teve os alunos para
visualizarem o trailer do filme josé e
pilar e por responderem online um
questionário de compreensão quanto todos
os alunos responderam ao questionário
projetei os gráficos com respostas para
serem comentados
este feedback enviado é muito muito
apreciado pelos alunos
depois por vírus que estivessem ao site
do escritor josé saramago
rylance em um texto autobiográfico mas à
medida que iam lendo o texto do frio e
fazendo sims até 50 critérios e publicá
los no twitter contaminassem 8 do texto
e ainda tem uma extensão considerável
deviam colocar duas três perguntas é
porque a encol de publicar também no
twitter para que os colegas
os descodificadores em e depois descem e
respostas desta maneira tornamos a
leitura mais flexível a e mais
interativa os jogos também fazem parte
dos do cardápio das minhas aulas
um dos jogos que olhou muito entusiasmo
foi o jogo quem quer ser um milionário
por sms
assim durante dez dias diariamente
enviava os alunos é uma pergunta de
escolha múltipla sobre os assuntos da
aula por sms ea verdade é que no final
dos cinco primeiros minutos
eu tenho no meu telemóvel mais limitada
respostas dos alunos está a atividade
serviu para ampliar as fronteiras da
sala de aula e tornar a aprendizagem
ubíqua podendo acontecer em qualquer
lugar ea qualquer hora
atualmente estou usar os sistemas de
respostas rápidas da audiência mais
conhecido por cliques e também em jogos
eletrônicos
estou a usar a plataforma é bastos ponte
neto tem vários editores dos jogos muito
fácil de usar e eu estou usar é um e
victor jogos do tipo caído mais
conhecido é o super mário
o formato que os alunos mais gostam é o
formato do tirol alvo
só que desta vez em vez de ser a atirar
ao alvo os marcianos e terá algumas
palavras que são resposta às perguntas
da aula
este jogo tem tempo tem é livre está em
finalização finalizações o que torna a
aula e aprendizagem dos conteúdos mais
rodrimar
motivadora mês o mais importante é que
quanto melhor souberem os conteúdos da
aula mais pontuações thai os alunos e
devo confessar que os alunos não gostam
de perder nem a feijões mas não tenhamos
ilusões não é tecnologia por si mas as
práticas pedagógicas que nós
desenvolvemos para atingir objetivos
educacionais
eu digo sempre a primeira pedagogia
depois a tecnologia para elevar os
níveis de literacia digital e sucesso
educativo não é o tempo total que o
aluno passa com a tecnologia mas o tempo
que gasta realizar tarefas específicas e
com elevado valor educacional e são
muitas as oportunidades que nós temos
para potenciar os dispositivos móveis
como ferramentas de aprendizagem
o limite é mesmo a nossa imaginação